Hello Freak bitches.
I mean everybody has their moments of
getting hot and then cold and you know,
you've have to hope if you get cold,
your head hot,
you know,
it's.
Yeah,
but
it's really fucking stupid.
I don't know,
like during that whole Chris Brown thing,
that's my only example.
So of course I was getting invited to
be on shows and talk about it and I
declined to everything.
It was like,
no,
I'm not good for you.
I was like,
absolutely not.
I wasn't the Chris Brown things.
We talked about it before the podcast,
but if people don't know Chris Brown
obviously was in trouble because was beat
up or Yana and that whole thing and you
know the domestic violence issue and you
tweeted something at him.
What did you tweet?
It was like my lowest form of comedy
writing is the celebrity reach weight.
It's because I can't think of anything
else and I'll just go to my favorite
targets like Hammer Kim Kardashians
and I only make fun of when they write
something stupid.
I never,
I never ever like I've never talked
about some of these looks their weight.
There you know,
like it's just when
something dumb and with his,
you know,
what he did,
he's a horrible person and he
had showed no signs of remorse.
Like he kept doing shit,
you know,
threw a chair through the window and
good morning America when Robin Roberts
interviewed him.
Yeah.
Well I mean like asking him about it and
apparently they had made some sort of
an agreement where they weren't
going to bring up domestic violence.
I'm here to talk about my album,
but the whole thing is,
it's like how he channeled his rage,
throwing a chair through
a fucking window really,
like you couldn't.
So I was born child and so I was born
and he had tweeted something like,
um,
man,
I look old as fuck and I'm only 23.
And so I retweeted it and I was like,
I know being a worthless piece
of shit can really aged person.
I thought it was funny and then all of
a sudden like I look at my replies on my
phone and it was like,
you don't look like that.
The waterfall of just like,
all of a sudden it was
like a thousand $2,000.
I'm like,
Holy Shit,
whoops.
What did I do?
And then I realized he was coming
back like telling me to suck his dick.
I'm like,
no,
your mother must be.
So like I just,
I played with them.
It was a Sunday.
I was bored and like next thing I know
is like he deleted his entire twitter
account and I feel like wow,
that's not what I meant to do.
Did he say one of the shit in
your mouth too short in my eye.
Your eye retina to be
specific.
I don't know.
I think he was trying to
sound smart beam accuracy.
Does he have with the is
even the back of the eye?
It's on,
in the front,
like he didn't even.
I think it's just trying to sound
smart and on your retina laughing away.
And I like he said like
ask Ron if she mad.
I'm like ask Anna if she man.
So like I tweeted back and then I linked
his police report to that tweet is a.
I thought it was funny and we went back
and forth for awhile and then he deleted
his account and that's when it a a thing.
Did he put it back up?
Is this back?
Yeah,
it wasn't really like down for like a
couple of weeks or something like that.
Can you delete your account when you put
it back to you get all your followers
back?
Do you have to start from scratch?
Start from scratch.
But I,
he has the most insane loyal
group of idiots that follow him.
Just misspelled death threats all day
long is what I got was just misspelled
death threats.
I was like,
well,
you know,
whoops.
But then the next day I was like,
my manager,
like I love the call that I got.
She's like,
Jenny,
um,
what did you do?
Have a lot of messages here.
And I was like,
yeah,
no,
my bad.
Like,
just tell them all.
No.
And she's like,
okay.
And she goes,
are you sure you don't want.
I've got good ones to view Larry King.
I was like,
no,
view is a good one.
How hilarious.
She's like,
she was totally not promoting this,
and she's like,
you got some good ones.
I want you to be on.
We got Larry King,
we get the view,
and I was like,
no,
no.
That's one way to do it,
and I've definitely done that way before.
I've done it.
A bunch of shitty.
What's the worst way you've ever done it?
I've just got the chicken nuggets way,
but right around that same time,
not,
not eating.
I remember,
so my first kickboxing fight ever.
I fought a guy named Andy Sour.
I don't know if you're
sure familiar with it.
That was your first kick?
My first kickboxing fight over fucking.
Is that your manager?
How long has andy been fighting then?
He is already his record at the time.
I remember two and for some 93 in one.
Oh my God,
that's so insane.
It through one and I was
first kickboxing fat.
All my ga,
I was 12 and O as an mma.
As an MMA fighter.
Oh my God.
I was 19 years old.
I had maybe one or two amateur boxing
fights and I had been training him or I'd
been trying to kickboxing for lots on,
but anyway,
I go up to 91,
92,
93 and one.
I remember.
Oh Man.
What fucking governing
body sanctioned that?
Uh,
it was in Japan.
I was basically,
I was,
I was the guy in Japan.
Exactly.
I was the guy that they were
bringing in for the slaughter.
Oh my God.
Uh,
I show up out there and I'm only,
I think I remember I was only like eight
pounds out and we didn't know what the
fuck we were doing with regards
to the weight cut at the time.
I was 19.
And so I'm like,
Oh shit.
And I just stopped eating.
I just didn't eat for about four days.
Oh No.
That's.
So meanwhile,
eight pounds ain't shit.
I'll do that.
Yeah.
The day before a crowd.
Oh,
we're good.
Yep,
exactly.
Still still eating one of the sauna.
Yeah.
God.
And so I started myself for about four
days and we check in your weight by
starving yourself.
Yeah,
I think it was,
I don't,
I don't remember.
It's a long time ago,
but it was same day weigh ins to.
Oh Christ.
I waited in the morning and then fall
about maybe eight or nine hours later.
Oh my God.
And uh,
I went five rounds with him.
Uh,
I went,
I,
it,
I got,
I got my ass kicked,
I got my ass kicked.
But I,
I learned a lot and I
grew from the experience.
The big
one,
you know,
that the film addresses is the,
is,
is the livestock,
you know,
that's what's got out of control and
that's what's literally destroying and
taking over the wildlife.
So if you really concerned about wildlife,
if you're real wildlife person,
the last thing you do
was not only consume,
say factory farm,
but that's the whole thing about our film.
People think it's about factory farms.
We don't even talk about factory farm.
We talk about the grass fed beef,
we talked about the organic,
the organic free range,
organic grass fed milk,
and that's what's killing the wildlife.
And that's the whole point of what we,
we,
we jumped past the factory farm
because ironically for wildlife,
if you care truly about wildlife
and that's what they discussed.
When we talk to any animal
agriculture alliance,
they say,
they say people think we're
living in somewhere 50 years ago,
100 years ago,
we're not,
we're living in a place
with 7 billion people.
The only way to efficiently fee
people who want to eat meat is to do,
put them in factory farms,
their factory firms,
because they're efficient.
They only take around two acres per cow.
Whereas is the grass fed cow.
You're talking about
your buddy in Wisconsin,
the guy in our film,
he had cattle in Wisconsin.
He said 50 acres.
Fifty acres for one fucking cow.
One cow.
Fifty acres,
50 acres.
Think how big that is.
No other wildlife can enter that.
So that's the last thing you'd
want to eat is grass fed beef.
The last thing you wanted to be fed is,
um,
would beating as these organic dairy
farms that is destroying all our water,
water resources,
polluting the rivers and
destroying all these predators.
And these,
uh,
you know,
the other wildlife that you talked about,
but the argument would be that when you
have a grass fed cow and it's eating on
50 acres,
that's where it's getting its food from.
Whereas if you have a factory raised
animals getting corn and that corn has
raised independently on
some other large area,
two acres,
two acres to.
Yeah,
because you can grow a corn
so much prager and grass fed,
it needs 50 acres that no other horse,
no other bear,
no other cougar know that all these
animals that you're talking about,
no other animal can live on that area.
Is that during the life of the animal?
That's,
that's just period.
That's just water.
Water that's constantly.
So imagine on a 50 foot fence.
Nothing else was way more than 50 foot
50 slash 50 acres or 50 acres for one.
So that's the last thing you want
to be eating is grassfed beef.
If you really care about the environment,
if you really care about wildlife,
you,
you need to say either our fuck the cow,
screw the cow,
the cow lives a miserable life.
But you know,
I care a lot about more like a,
you know,
about the,
the elk and the Moose and the wolves.
I care more about wildlife
than I do about this cow.
You got to choose one or the
other if you're going to do it.
And if you really care about wildlife,
you got to say screw the cow.
And then Sco,
uh,
with factory farm.
And that's the whole irony of this whole
grass fed myth that's happening and
what's,
that's what's kind of
ironic about the film.
And people don't expect that shocking.